Hilary Clinton goes off on gun control
Nicholas Kristof of the New York Times
tries to explain the Second Amendment
and we checked the mailbag is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
all right we have a lot to get to here
today with a particularly full segment
of mailbag Lurie today that a lot of
people have written in in the mail and
they want their questions answered and
since it is our first week on syndicated
radio we are going to have a lot of
opportunity to explore a broader than
normal mailbag but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at bit
IRA so you've heard all the stuff about
millionaire next door and the Bitcoin
Bitcoin millionaire next door but here's
the thing okay cryptocurrency is
actually a good investment or at least
it can be a good investment George
Gilder who's one of my economic mentors
a guy who I really believe when he talks
about economics says Bitcoin is the
perfect libertarian solution to the
money enigma now what you've heard about
Bitcoin has been about the volatility or
maybe you've heard about the enormous
amounts of money people are making in it
but what what coin really is like gold
or silver it is an assets that the
government cannot control and cannot
touch and if you put your money in it is
a great hedge against inflation and
government intervention ISM and because
bitcoin is still growing it could also
be a very good investment if you put
your money in and more people buy into
Bitcoin then the Bitcoin prices go up
because the limit Bitcoin is is based on
a limited supply so if there's a limited
supply Bitcoin more people are buying in
the value goes up so if you get an early
on Bitcoin you tend to do better over
time just as if you invested in gold
very early before a massive supply was
increased then you'd do really well on
gold as well well the folks the folks
from Birch gold group the same people
who help you purchase precious metals
for your IRA have created a new company
and it's called bit IRA and it helps you
tap your IRA or 401k into the growth
potential of crypto currencies to help
you learn more bit IRA actually offers a
free copy of their essential guide to
digital IRAs which you can claim at bit
IRA dot-com slash Bend that's bit IRA
com / ben if you have over 20,000
dollars in an IRA or 401k go-to bit IRA
comm slash Ben get free info guide with
zero obligation to you again that's bi
TIR a.com slash Ben ask all your
questions get all your answers and then
if you're interested in putting a little
bit of money in cryptocurrency again as
a hedge against inflation and government
intervention then go over to bit IRA
dot-com slash Ben that's bit IRA dot-com
slash Ben to check it out ok so Hilary
Clinton is back in the news again she
just will not leave under any
circumstances and no matter what she
cannot be pushed out
we'll push Hillary Clinton off and she
she's like that the Jennifer Hudson in
Dreamgirls right she is telling you
she's not going she were the best man
she'll ever know and she's not going to
Hillary Clinton is just gonna stick
around and now she's gonna be talking
about gun control so she is praising the
power Clinton she's saying they're
changing the conversation this is the
great myth of the left is that the
conversation is routinely being changed
even though the conversation is exactly
the same as it ever was here's Hillary
Clinton the one of the the worst not one
of the worst the worst candidate
American history who will not leave
still talking about gun control and
parkland so what we've got to do is to
say we're produced on weapons ban we're
for universal background checks we are
going to hold elected officials
accountable and we're going to vote
against those who will not agree with
those particular policies and I think
we've got a real shot to defeat the NRA
again the problem is it never ends oh
sorry I fell asleep Hillary Clinton is
talking my bad okay so we're back but
she's not the only one who's pushing the
idea that the gun control issue is now
on the table and Democrats finally have
the advantage because of the parkland
teen zoo the parkland things okay so one
of these folks is pushing this idea is
Nicholas Kristof was one of the worst
colonists in America he writes for the
New York Times op-ed page which of
course means that by definition he's one
of the worst columnist in America the
New York Times op-ed page is a trash
heap of misery and and stupidity but in
any case here is what he writes he has
an entire column this week talking about
the Second Amendment and it's called how
to win an argument about guns so I
thought to myself well if Nicholas
Kristof knows how to win an argument
about guns maybe we'd better read those
arguments because maybe he's finally
given a guide to the left on how they
can defeat the Second Amendment agenda
Wow I mean maybe he's finally broken the
code it turns out not so much so here's
what he writes
tragically predictably infuriatingly
we're again morning a shooting this time
at youtube's headquarters even as the
for gun safety legislation installed in
Washington polls showed that nine out of
ten Americans favored basic steps like
universal background checks before gun
purchases but the exceptions are the
President and a majority in Congress now
this alone should make you stop and
think well why is it that if nine out of
ten people think one thing but a
majority of people in Congress who are
elected by those same people think
another thing why that's asperity well
the answer is of course that nine out of
ten people do not support universal
background checks nine out of ten people
are told a slogan called universal
background checks and then when they are
told that this means that you will not
be able to give your gun to your kid
right when this means that you will not
be able to buy a gun for your brother
when this means that you won't be able
to lend a gun to your friend to go
hunting they go well that seems weird
like that's I'm not up for that so all
these polls mean nothing in any case the
Nicholas Kristof continues usually
pundits toss out their bet their own
best arguments while ignoring the other
sides but today I'm going to try
something new and to engage directly
with the arguments made by gun advocates
quote you liberals are in a panic over
guns but look at the numbers any one gun
is less likely to kill a person than any
one vehicle but we're not traumatized by
cars and we don't try to ban them so
here's how Nicholas Kristof responds to
this claim it is true that any
particular car is more likely to be
involved in a fatality than any
particular gun but cars are actually a
perfect example of the public health
approach we should apply to guns we
don't ban cards but we do work hard to
take a dangerous product and regulate it
to limit the damage there are already
federal background checks on guns you
cannot own a machine gun states across
the country have gun legislation that
restricts magazine size I was recently
at a gun shop in California and in
California if you buy a rifle you cannot
actually have replaceable magazine you
literally have to unscrew every magazine
that you use use a magazine you use the
limit you have to unscrew the magazine
you take out a screwdriver and release
the magazine before putting in a new
magazine Andry screwing it in okay so
these gun laws exist all over the United
States and kristoff apparently doesn't
know that he says we do that through
seatbelts and airbags with cars through
speed limits and highway barriers
through driver's licenses and insurance
requirements through crackdowns on
drunken driving and texting while
driving I once calculated that since
1921 we have reduced the auto fatality
rate per 100 million miles driven by 95
percent sure we could have just said the
cars don't kill people people kill
people or it could have said it's
pointless to regulate cars because then
bicyclists will just run each other
down instead we relied on evidence and
data to reduce the carnage from cars why
isn't that a model for guns well here's
the part that's hilarious about this
entire argument that he's in out
proclaiming he's saying that we've done
a great job with cars except that cars
still kill more people than guns right
so how is that how does that follow
right if the idea is that all these
regulations on cars have made them less
deadly why is the guns as a percentage
of the population and the guns the
number of guns in American society has
increased wildly since 1994 and yet the
gun death rate in the United States has
decreased wildly since 1994 he just sort
of skips over that part okay Nicholas
Kristof continues because of the Second
Amendment the Constitution doesn't
protect vehicles but it does protect my
right to a gun he says yes but courts
have found the Second Amendment does not
prevent sensible regulation there is no
constitutional objection to say
universal background checks to obtain a
gun it's crazy the 22 percent of guns
are obtained without a check again he's
right on this one okay there is nothing
in the Constitution that says you cannot
have a universal background check it is
also politically unpalatable because a
lot of people don't want a universal
background check then says whoa again
this is Christoph going back and forth
trying to explain why all the
conservative arguments on guns are wrong
says whoa you're inflating the gun
violence numbers by including suicides
almost two-thirds of those gun deaths
are suicides in the blunt reality is
that if someone wants to kill himself
will find a way it's not about guns is
actually that's not true scholars have
found that suicide barriers on bridges
for example prevent jumpers and don't
lead to a significant increase in
suicides elsewhere okay first of all
they're like five jumpers in the United
States okay the number of people who die
by jumping off bridges in the United
States every year is really really low
so that's not a great sample size and
they says likewise almost half of
suicides in Britain used to be by
asphyxiation oneself with gas from the
oven when Britain switched to a less
lethal oven gas the suicides by oven
plummeted and there was little
substitution by other methods so it is
about guns well no that's like saying
that it was that suicide was about ovens
in Britain okay suicide is much more
common on a per capita basis in many
countries in Europe than it is in the
United States where guns are not nearly
as prevalent the suicide rates in Japan
continue to be quite high for example
and guns are essentially forbidden in
that society the evidence on the to
pretend that guns are the cause of
suicide is just a name a suicide is
something social scientists have been
studying for nigh on two hundred years
right really since
and they're still waiting to figure out
exactly how this functions people don't
understand why people commit suicide
there's no good one answer to it and
suggest it's all about the guns is just
dumb he says no it's more about our
violent culture the Swiss and Israelis
have large numbers of firearms and they
don't have our levels of gun violence
says yes there's something to that
America has underlying social problems
and we need to address them with smarter
economic and social policies but we
magnify the toll when we make it easy
for troubled people to explode with
ar-15s rather than with pocket knives
well there's not a lot of evidence to
that and that doesn't rebut the
supposition which is that a good person
with a gun stops a bad person with a gun
and if a bad person gets a hold of a gun
you don't want to be armed with a
pocketknife in fact then violence rates
vary widely across American society if
we're really looking to save lives maybe
we should stop with the gun confiscation
rhetoric and start talking instead about
how exactly we should stop all these
underlying social problems that are
causing the crime in the first place
and finally the Nicholas Kristof writes
you liberals freaked out about guns if
you have a swimming pool or a bathtub
that's more dangerous to neighborhood
kids than a gun is kids under age 14 are
much more likely to die from drowning
than from firearms so why this crusade
against guns but not against bathtubs
and pools
so here's Christoph's response your
numbers are basically right but only
because young children routinely swim
and take baths but don't regularly
encounter firearms right because the
vast majority of people with firearms
lock them up there are 300 million
firearms in the United States there are
100 million gun owners in the United
States my guess that there are fewer
pools than that in all of the United
States because 300 million pools would
be a lot of pools in the United States I
don't think there's that many pools in
the United States okay so he says look
at the picture of the population as a
whole
overall 3,600 Americans drown each year
while 36,000 die from guns yes including
suicides there's one more reason to be
talking more about gun safety than about
pool safety well no that's more of a
reason to be talking than to be talking
about why guns should stay away from
kids and why again if we're so
apparently we're not allowed to talk
about deaths from cars because something
and we shouldn't talk about death from
pools because guns guns outs are more
common than pool deaths even though if
we talk about guns and pools then we
come up with the conclusion that pulls
her more dangerous to children than guns
none of this makes any sense
finally since note that a backyard pool
is it going to be used - mother neighbor
or to invade in nearby school schools
don't have drills for
active pool situation okay that's an
emotional argument not really a logical
one
he said well some 200,000 guns are
stolen each year it's more difficult to
steal the pool and use it for a violent
purpose okay so now he's calling for a
full-scale gun confiscation and then
telling us why we shouldn't worry about
that
so again Nicholas Kristof defeating his
own arguments well done there Nicholas
Kristof just strong stuff from the New
York Times columnist David French has an
excellent column on all of this and any
points out that all the straw man that
Nicholas Kristof erect here do not do
not even withstand Nicholas Kristof's
attempt to / a22 undercut its undercut
those arguments that hit the arguments
that he props up there are actually
stronger than his counter arguments
French says Christophe won't win his
argument because he can't we've proven
we can decrease crime while we protect
the Second Amendment and expand access
to guns we know we can reduce suicides
without restricting any person's right
to self-defense we know we have fewer
suicides than many other developed
countries even as we have more guns
moreover we know that various so-called
dominant common-sense gun control
measures wouldn't have prevented a
single recent shooting and David French
certainly is right about all of that
okay so in just a second I want to
discuss the latest over at Facebook
where disaster has broken out yet again
but this time over something that I
don't really think is Facebook's fault
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at skills chair so skill
share is the place to go for you to
broaden and deepen your resume okay your
you need to make your skill set better
you do if you want a better job if you
want to raise it the job that you are
currently at you need to go to skill
share calm and take a class with the
experts over there Skillshare is an
online learning platform with over
18,000 classes in design business
technology and more you can take classes
in graphic design we here at the office
take social media marketing marketing
search engine optimization they have
classes on just about everything they're
a lifelong learning tool and it is just
great now I've even taken a class on
watercolours just for the fun of it from
Skillshare join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today and
we have a special offer just for my
listeners you get two months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents so
Skillshare is offering Ben Shapiro short
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 18,000 classes for just 99 cents
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
Shapiro that Skillshare comm slash
apparel to start your two months now
that Skillshare comm slash apparel
getting get 99 cents two months of
Skillshare it's really a great service
and there's a reason that we have all of
our employees take skill share
classes you should - you want a better
job you want to get paid more this is
the way to do it Skillshare comm /a
Pierrot
also lets them know that we sent you
okay so meanwhile Facebook has gotten
itself into some hot water
why because on Wednesday they said that
most of its users who had a specific
search function enabled had had their
profile scraped by third parties the
Zuckerberg sat on a call with reporters
what we've seen some scraping scraping
is where companies go into Facebook and
they look at your public profile and
then they take all the information off
of it so that they can date a mine on
you he says I would assume if you had
that setting turned on that someone at
some point has access to your public
information in some way he the setting
he's referring to is one where users let
other users search for them by email
address or phone number rather than just
by name so their chief technology
officer Mike Schroepfer said most
Facebook users could have had their
public profile scraped he said quote
until today people could enter another
person's phone number or email address
into Facebook search to help find them
there's been especially useful for
finding your friends and languages which
take more effort to type out a full name
or where many people have the same name
in Bangladesh for example this feature
makes up 7% of all searches however
malicious actors have also abused these
features to scrape public profile
information by submitting phone numbers
or email addresses they already have
thought they already have through search
and account recovery and given the scale
and sophistication of the activity we've
seen we believe most people on Facebook
could have had their public profile
scraped in this way so a lot of people
are very upset about this because all
Cambridge analytical was scraping public
information and using it in order to
cross tabulate with political preference
and now other companies are doing this
guys the Internet is not private if you
put a profile on Facebook other people
can see it that is the purpose of it if
you think marketing companies are not
taking advantage of that you don't know
anything about social media so this one
is not on Facebook what is on Facebook
is that they have lost the trust of the
American people because Facebook has not
been transparent about what exactly
their purpose is about what it is that
they do are they a social media platform
or you interact with friends and people
you want to follow or are they a
publisher that decides what you see if
they're going to act like this kind of
panopticon's company that is going to
expose all of your information to
various sites and then also going to
dictate what it is that you see then you
feel a little more boxed in than if we
say listen you have a profile you put it
up there it is what it is if people take
it and use it that's their problem but
at least you
to see what you see and interact how you
want to interact now Facebook has some
real problems
along all of these lines specifically
because they've not been clear about
what it is that they do if they want to
be clear about what they do if they want
to be transparent with the people who
use Facebook now is the time I
understand that they don't want to give
away proprietary trade secrets but
that's not what we're asking for all
we're asking for is to know how are you
deciding what shows up in my feed how
are you deciding what information is
protected these are not difficult
questions these are questions that
should be easy to answer and if Facebook
answers those questions
I think the consumers at that point can
make an informed decision okay so now I
want to talk a little bit about the
latest on the stormy Daniel scandal
whose stormy Daniels so the left is
obsessed with the stormy Daniels story
because sir McDaniels is a porn actress
who has been in many a massive
masterpiece including the witches of
breast wick in actual film in which
stormy Daniels start I'm not kidding and
she also obviously had an affair with
the President of the United States all
the talk about Trump denying that like
come on come on does anyone really
believe President Trump on that probably
not because it's just not particularly
believable but one of the things the
media have done with stormy Daniels is
they have made her out to be a victim
they've said that this porn star who had
an affair with the President of the
United States before he was president
knowing he was married in an attempt to
get him to put her on Celebrity
Apprentice and then took one hundred one
hundred thirty thousand dollars to shut
up about it before the election now
she's some sort of great victim and
she's really a hero storming jamuns you
know she's really coming out with
information that the public needs to
know now I'm not saying the Trump is
innocent in all of this he's not he
bribed the woman to shut up about an
affair that he had while he was married
that's disgusting
okay plus I mean having sex with stormy
Daniels is not exactly
virgin territory okay but in any case
you know when when President Trump when
President Trump you know insists that he
is completely innocent in all of this no
he's not innocent in all of this having
a lawyer pay people pay people off to
shut up about affairs is gross behavior
is it illegal maybe maybe not probably
not
is it a campaign finance violations
probably not which means that I think it
raises moral questions about the
president but those moral questions have
been an offering for something like 40
years at this point I mean there's
nothing new Under the Sun here and
there's a nothing new under stormy
Daniels
apparently so this idea that the
president has has somehow violated the
trust of his own base like everybody
knew that this is what Trump was when
they elected him come on
Melania was wife number three okay this
is not like wow this guy is just he's a
paragon of moral rectitude and so what
why exactly is the media obsessed with
this because they think this is gonna
take down Trump and they've painted
stormy Daniels as some sort of
victimized figure by President Trump
well all of that sort of exploded on the
Democrats yesterday because stormy
Daniels hit her lawyer Michael a vanetti
was interviewed by megyn kelly
megyn kelly is a fantastic interviewer
she's a great prosecutor right this is
what she is best at right the stuff that
she's best at I you know I think she's
okay at all of the kind of morning show
host tennis stuff but the stuff that
Meghan just dominates him that she's
terrific at is when she asks hard
questions to people she was great at
this on Fox News and she just grilled
Michael a vanetti last night and it was
brutal why would you why would stormy
Daniels be leading the charge on whether
whether that payment violated the
election law because and I mean this is
the honest-to-god truth this is a
principled woman at this point she wants
the truth she wants the truth now now
they're laughing at you know what she
said principled that 11 days before the
election she had information about the
possible next president having an
extramarital affair with a with an adult
film actress and she shut up about it in
exchange for just over a hundred grand
yeah and I think she's providing an
explanation as to why that is it's
because she wanted the money she wants
she wants that she wants the truth to be
known to the American people and why'd
she take the money why didn't she just
talk 11 days before the election you'd
have to ask her that I don't have a nice
come on she wanted the dough okay so
this is where megyn kelly is fantastic
of every show or like this with megyn
kelly her ready to be phenomenal because
that's amazing television that is so
good
and she's exactly right of course it's
amazing how the media can't scan any of
these psychological cognitive dissonance
that that people experience every day in
order for them to say that Trump did
something bad her they have to say the
stormy Daniels is some sort of heroin
stormy Daniels is kind of gross okay
this is a woman who had an affair with a
married man you know it again on a
television show and then took a bunch of
money to shut up about it before the
election and now she no she will make
more money if she doesn't take that
money start so the best part
this was Megan Kelly actually asked
Michael a vanity listen if she didn't
want the money then why is it still in
her bank account like you could just
give the money back right that could be
a thing that would actually happen and
that is not what happened right I mean
so associated not actually give the
money back obviously and the and the
impact of that is that she shut up for
the for the duration of the election
pretty amazing stuff so good for Meghan
Kelly for finally asking some questions
it just shows the desperation of the
left that they've tried to make some
sort of martyr out of stormy Daniels
who's anything but a martyr anything but
a martyr amazing amazing stuff again I
want more of this from Meghan Kelly I
would watch this show every day like
this right here I would watch that every
day I would just replay that clip over
and over because megyn kelly shellacking
Michael have an Eddie is something that
is long overdue and demonstrates really
the lack of objective media experience
on the part of the media right the media
say their objective they're not if
they're really objective they all would
have been asking Michael a vendetta
these questions weeks ago but I took
Meghan Kelly to ask it on a morning show
on NBC News in order for them to be
asked okay so now it is time for some
mailbag correct is it mailbag time yeah
let's do some mailbag all right so we
have some really good mailbag Guri today
so you all have sent us some great
questions and I want to take some time
with them so we begin today's mailbag
with an email from George George is a
young guy who apparently lives in
Sacramento and he writes that hi Ben I'm
the guy in the al-jazeera plus video
that went viral over the weekend in
connection with the Stephon Clarke
protests I was wondering if there was
any suggestion you could give me on how
best to respond I'm an avid fan and
subscriber okay so here is what the
video looked like here's what the video
sounded like and I will explain to you
what exactly is happening in the video
I'm looking at it as we do the show and
now I'm going to explain to you what's
in it so that you can actually hear
what's going on so what it looks like
his young white guy is in a BMW he pulls
up to a route that has been blocked off
by protesters these protesters are
protesting after the death of Stefan
Clark who's a black guy who was shot to
death under what would be
extraordinarily refuted circumstances in
Sacramento the police were chasing
apparently a black suspect through her
neighborhood they ended up in this guy's
backyard this guy was just out back on
his cell phone and they shot him to
death for no reason it's an amazing
amazing story and really a travesty and
demonstrates lack of police training
and you know how bad things can get when
you're in a crime-ridden neighborhood
and the cops responsible are definitely
gonna spend some time in jail I think
and certainly for police malfeasance but
in any case these protesters have
blocked off the intersection and the the
person who wrote me this letter George
he steps out of his BMW to talk with the
protesters because he's just standing
there and they're blocking traffic and
here's what it sounds like he says and
so he says you can tell by the way he
answered all the people yelling at me
cynically do you honestly expect this
medium of protesting is going to serve
your purpose well do you truly believe
that he said I'm not going anywhere and
then they're all yelling at him you're
crazy we're not going anyone this bleep
crazy you can't go nowhere man
and they said I don't at all dispute or
invalidate or devalue anything you're
trying to do and then a guy yells at him
if your brother got killed
then you'd be saying different he says
my brother did get killed okay and the
other guy says well the other guy says
well if you were if you were shot by
police for no reason then it would be
something different he says you have
every right to voice what you're doing
but what I'm getting at is you have
sidewalks right and they're yelling at
him and they're screaming at him and
they're saying that he's a terrible
person he's saying I can't speak right
you're not even letting me talk and make
my argument and they all start talking
about how he's a racist
they're saying you shakin come on bro
just hop in your sweet car and people
are telling the media not to pay
attention to any of this so this went
viral and Al Jazeera says was this a
meaningful conversation where was this
guy just trying to exercise his white
privilege to get home okay so let me ask
let me start by asking a question is it
a white privilege to get home is that a
thing now like why is it a white
privilege to get home I wasn't aware
that it was a racial thing if you want
to get home like seriously I don't
understand why that that has anything to
do with white privilege so the argument
here is apparently that he is a racist
for even objecting to the streets being
stopped presumably without a permit
because if there been a permit there
would have been street signs directing
people around the protest but instead
you get stuck at this intersection and
the idea is that everybody is supposed
to just deal with it okay so George
here's what I would say you did nothing
wrong here I think that you know there's
there's an attempt to do a race
class war on the part of the left based
on this video they're trying to say that
because you're white and because you
were driving a BMW this means that your
argument is no longer valid but your
argument is valid if you're a Hispanic
guy driving a Honda Civic your argument
be just as valid you want to get home
why are people blocking the public
thoroughfare and there's nothing wrong
with you asking that question by the way
it is also true that what you are
arguing that you actually agree with the
protesters right and that you want them
to do something more effective for their
cause the data back you up
okay the data show that there poet
there's polling data that shows this
from the Atlantic and what it shows is
that if you block traffic people are
less likely to listen to your message
people are more likely in fact to think
that you're a jerk who's blocking
traffic so what you were doing there was
attempting to say to these folks listen
I'm on your side and isn't just about me
getting home if you actually want to do
something effective that raises sympathy
levels then go get a permit and then
protest because no one's stopping you
from protesting we just don't want you
shutting down traffic in middle of
rush-hour so you can't get home there's
nothing unreasonable about that
and by the way it is worth noting that
when people say well Martin Luther King
you know he be shut down highways yes
there was a federal court order that was
issued that allowed the Selma to that
the Selma March to happen okay so there
the entire history of the Selma March is
really really interesting and there's an
interesting column by again and Ronald
crossed ocinski that was written in 2015
for the LA Times in which he talks about
the legality of the Selma March so first
of all you have to he's a professor at
the University of Alabama law school is
this is this professor and he served as
a law clerk to judge Frank Johnson in
1991 1992 so first you have to determine
is the purpose of the march to get
arrested
sometimes the purpose of the margin is
to get arrested because you want to show
that you're being under you're being
arrested for an unjust reason but it is
also worthwhile noting that a lot of the
time you can have a protest and the goal
of the protest is to gain public
sympathy and the worst way to do that is
by shutting down traffic so here is what
this law professor writes quote to mark
the 50th anniversary of the Selma
marches of 1965 we'll replay the
inspirational words of Reverend Martin
Luther King jr. recount the courage of
the marchers in the face of police
brutality and recall the shock to the
conscience that led to the passage of
the Voting Rights Act but we should also
consider an important question could a
march like Selma happen today the 52
mile march down u.s. highway 80 on March
21st through 20
required more than determination it
required a court order after Alabama
state troopers and local sheriff's
deputies attacked the 600 people
crossing the Edmund Pettus Bridge on
Bloody Sunday March 7th the Southern
Christian Leadership Conference went to
federal court on Monday to ask for an
immediate injunction ordering Alabama
state officials to permit the March to
proceed they didn't get it by US
District Court Judge Frank Johnson jr.
scheduled a hearing for later that week
in the meantime he ordered the SCLC not
to march from Selma to Montgomery King
was under tremendous pressure to proceed
even if doing so might land him in
contempt of court
in the end what did King do he respected
the court's order and so on tuesday
march across the Edmund Pettus Bridge
but then returned to Selma after a
four-day hearing Johnson held the March
could proceed and then they were
protected by federal troops all the way
hey so King Abbott abided by the law
because he understood he understood that
he didn't want the scene of people being
beaten presumably for breaking law
instead what he wanted was if people
were going to be attacked he wanted them
to be attacked while abiding by the law
right the whole goal of King's March
here was to demonstrate that people
could abide by the law and still be
treated unequally that was the whole
point so the question here is number one
what are these people protesting are
they protesting police brutality are
they protesting for new police
procedures that's one thing if they are
protesting however the idea that the
police are generally racist or that
America is generally racist and they're
gonna shut down traffic to do it I do
not understand the logic of that so
George your question was your what what
how should you best respond I think that
you should write all of this I think
that you should write a letter an open
letter saying here is why I was talking
to the protesters I was trying to help
them it wasn't just about me getting
home I was trying to recommend that they
pick a better way of doing this so that
their message is better heard and more
concerted and then I can join them
because I'd like to stand out there and
March with them and I can't March with
them when I'm stuck in my car I can't
just leave my car there right side what
I would like is a scheduled March and a
legal time in place that I can join
because that will also be the most
effective with a message that I can join
into not saying the police are
systematically racist and systemically
racist without evidence but saying that
the police need new procedures and we
need to figure out how best to educate
cops that these sorts of mistakes don't
happen in the US military when they do
they are very often end with the
court-martial so you know again the the
real travesty in that video is nothing
that was done
said Bayou George the real travesty is
the people who are standing there
shouting at you that you're a racist
because you're asking a serious question
and the people who are on al-jazeera are
claiming that it's white privilege for
you to even ask the question as though a
white person couldn't March with black
people there were white people who are
marching with MLK in Selma and I'm sure
that there are white people who will
march on behalf of Stephon Clarke as
they should because that shooting is
egregious okay other questions from the
mailbag sarah says hi Ben has there ever
been a time in history the Democrats
were actually a good party I can't say
that Republicans are great right now but
you carried the monocore party of
Lincoln as well as a few others does the
Democratic Party have a highlight like
that that we as conservatives can look
back at and say oh why don't they go
back to being like that also are there
any books that give a balanced history
about the history of both parties they
might might recommend thanks for being
awesome well Sarah I appreciate it and
you're welcome for being awesome but
here is the here's the answer about the
parties um it's very difficult for me to
say that the parties overall are great
or bad there are certain policies that
parties have embraced in the past that
are very good so the Democratic Party
for example did embrace the civil rights
movement they did a little bit late but
they did it right the Democratic Party
did embrace detect cuts under JFK for
example they were cold warriors under
JFK although not to the same extent as
some Republicans FDR's
the way that he operated World War two
with the exception of Japanese
internment was was great so Democrats
have done great things in the past and
to ignore that would be to ignore
history but to say the Democratic Party
was ever great as a whole I have a
problem with that just like I don't
think the Republican Party was ever that
great as a whole I think there have been
things in the Republican Party that have
been great I would say that radical
reconstruction Republicans were great I
would say that Lincoln was great I would
say Reagan was great but there been
times that the Republican Party has
backed some really pretty stupid policy
you know there was a time when the
typical country club Republican was
considered a guy who wouldn't open his
golf club to Jews so what I would
suggest is instead of following party
banners and saying you know that the
Democrats were always greater the
Republicans were always great you can
say here are good people
now which party best represents those
causes and people now that's the more
important thing I don't think the labels
matter nearly as much as as people seem
to think that they do okay well I have
more of these questions that I want to
answer but first you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wire calm for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to
daily wire calm when you do you get the
rest of my show live get the rest of
Clavin show live
get the rest of the the michael most
rely plus there's an episode of the
conversation coming up on tuesday andrew
Clavin will be answering all of your
questions live in live like as in you go
on daily wire and if you're a subscriber
you type questions into the chat box and
you'll answer your questions anyone can
watch at youtube or facebook or on our
website but you can only watch on our
website and ask questions if you go to
daily wire comm and become a subscriber
that's $9.99 a month for $99 a year you
also get the magical leftist tears hot
or called tumblr so better price and you
get the mug so check that out we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so more questions from the
mailbag here we go Scott says hi Ben
why do you think Jews on the hold lean
left this is my interpretation of
polling data given history I fail to
understand the reasoning for this thanks
love the show
okay Scott so here is here is why so
Jews lean left because most Jews are not
observant most Jews do not pay attention
to Jewish law they do not pay attention
to the Torah they do not really pay
attention to Israel Jews are by polling
numbers the most atheistic religious
group in America so when you poll Jews
you're pulling a bunch of people who say
they are ethnically Jewish but have
never attended synagogue or do so once a
year on Yom Kippur and then they break
for lunch right even though Yom Kippur
is a fast day so you can't take that
seriously as a representative of Judaism
so when you say why did you vote left
for the same reason that most ethnically
white people living in major in major
blue states in major blue cities leans
to the left with high levels of
education and an upper class income
right that's the description of the
normal non religious Jew that's reason
number one reason number two is that
there are a lot of Jews who think that
the best way that so the reason that
Jews have been active in leftist
movements like socialism historically is
because socialism promised that it was
gonna get over anti-semitism Jews who
are living in in Tsarist Russia or
victimized by anti-semitism on a regular
basis now as it turns out socialism in
the Soviet Union didn't cure that right
anti-semitism continued to be a thing
hey Jews were still dramatically
victimized under the USSR but there were
a lot of Jews involved in the socialist
movement because they thought that if we
could see each other as a brotherhood of
man and get beyond religion then maybe
Jews would finally be treated with
enlightenment equality that of course
did not happen
plus there are a lot of Jews who react
to Christians with a certain level of
antipathy which i think is not justified
by a Christian behavior at least in the
modern era I think that there are a lot
of Jews who go back you know 100 years
and they say that a lot of anti-semitism
was driven by Christians and so why
would we ally with Christians now
whichever party is more Pro Christian as
the one I'm not going to be a part of
again this describes why secular Jews
are anti Republican and anti right it
does not describe why religious Jews are
because religious Jews aren't the dirty
little secret is that Orthodox religious
Jews but about 70/30 Republican okay
Timothy says hi Ben I'm a senior in high
school and I wondered what protections
or rights you think animals should have
what is your view on animal conservation
do you think it serves any purpose so
I'm in favor of animal conservation I
think we should be saving as many of the
endangered species as we can because we
were given the earth to guard and
cultivate even biblically speaking as
far as what rights animals should have
they have the right against excessive
cruelty I don't think anyone should be
cruel to animals as far as meat-eating
it seems to me that from what I've heard
from my wife anyway she she says and she
is a doctor as you may know she says
that the that the human body does
require a lot of the nutrients in meat
so that is a reason for meat eating out
of necessity but the idea that that
animals should be cruelly treated I
think is forbidden by virtually every
major Western religion daniel says hi
Ben earlier this week he talked about
marriage and having kids and that having
kids makes you extremely happy and
someone who's not married in his home
and isn't sure if I want kids I wanted
to know what you thought having kids
would be like before you have them did
you have an idea of how happy you would
be or is a completely different
experience than you were expecting well
it wasn't like I thought that everything
with kids is gonna be wonderful rainbows
and sunshine and unicorns again as they
say when you have kids the spectrum of
happiness wildly expands which means
that you go from a possible 10 out of 10
to a 1,000 out of 10 but it also goes to
a negative 1,000 right so that means
that the worst suffering you will do is
when your child suffers or when your
child misbehaves or does something bad
and the best your life will be is when
your child does something good but you
should have kids because you having kids
makes you a better person and because I
think you have an obligation to
contribute as a as a solid thinker to
the betterment of humanity through the
next generation creating a next
generation of people who will help
preserve values that matter so I think
it's more a matter of obligation than
enjoyment in other words having children
what if I you know I think it's met
expectations in terms of happiness I
think it's it's exceeded expectations in
terms of amount of work because it's an
enormous amount of work to have children
and it changes your life dramatically
you will never sleep again nor will you
ever have a night off again at least
until your kids hit 21 and even then
you'll stay up nights wondering what
their kids are doing with their life so
yeah it's a lot of work you know I joke
that it sort of like a cult having kids
then once you once you have kids
you have to convince other people to
join the cult but you can't tell people
about the downsides because then they
won't want to join and then once they're
in they now feel a moral obligation to
spread the spread the good word so but
it is it is an amazing experience it'll
make you a better human being okay more
questions from the mailbag Spencer says
what
your perspective on the 17th amendment
many modern conservatives including Mike
Lee believe the direct election of
senators has resulted in a submit severe
diminution of state power and
contributed to the massive expansion of
the federal government during the 20th
century do you share this view or are
you more sympathetic toward the 17th
amendment no I definitely share that
view I know Zell Miller the senator from
Georgia who recently passed away he was
a big advocate of changing the 17th
amendment so that it was elected by
state legislators the reason for that is
because when you directly elect senators
then they become your federal
representatives as opposed to being
people who are standing there in favor
of the state's interest they no longer
represent the state because the state's
interests are best represented by the
interests of the legislature instead
they are representing the public at
large and it's easier to fool the public
at large than it is to fool state
legislators we actually have a stake in
maintaining a certain amount of state
power like people don't follow politics
closely enough to elect state to tell
elect senators who are going to stand up
for the for the values of the state but
they do have the values to elect those
people to state legislature later and
then the state legislature wants to
guard its own its own power and so they
tell the Senators what to do and what
not to do Lucas says as someone who has
never been spanked I've always held that
spanking children is counterproductive
and teaches them to abstain from
behaving badly not out of moral
understanding but out of fear of
physical punishment in addition children
who are spanked my parents are more
likely to physically hurt other kids
still many conservatives hold that
spanking is good practice what is your
stance on spanking so we do not spank I
am NOT a big fan of corporal punishment
and when I was growing up it wasn't that
my parents had an ideological boundary
against spanking I think I was spanked
maybe once my sister was spanked maybe
twice in like her entire childhood and a
couple of my sisters weren't spanked at
all the only time I think that it is
appropriate to spank honestly speaking
the only time I think it is appropriate
to spank is when your kid is doing
something dangerous so if you have a
three-year-old who's continuing to run
into the street and you say don't run
into the street and three-year-old runs
in the street and you say don't run into
the street because you will get hit by a
car and three-year-old runs into the
street I think it is appropriate as a
physical deterrent to say if you run
into the street you will get a patch and
then open-palm but I think is the proper
way to do it I know there are others who
disagree but I think this is a proper
way to do it but the only time to do it
really is literally the same way you
would with in animals who train an
animal not to run into the street right
and that's that's all it's more for
moral suasion I'm not
huge fan of spanking because I think
that kids then don't know the reason why
they're doing what they are doing and
kids should learn to obey you without
you having to threaten them with
physical punishment hey there are other
forms of punishment that you can use
like we're constantly saying like my
daughter knows that if she disobeys I
say you sweetheart if you do this then
you're violating the rules and the rules
say you have to get a punishment right I
don't even have to tell her what the
punishment is and she immediately starts
crying like she knows that she doesn't
want the punishment usually the
punishment is something pretty anodyne
usually it's something like you can't
watch TV tomorrow or you're not gonna
have any sweets this weekend something
like that and then you have to stick
with it right if you actually punish the
kid there has to be an actual punishment
that attaches you can't keep playing
chicken with the kid because then the
kid knows that if they cry a little bit
they get what they want anyway after
being bad now Wyatt says hi Ben I'm a
West Texas High School junior attending
Central High School currently I'm taking
all advanced level courses along with
one periods voted to helping a teacher
grade papers take role etc throughout my
years in high school I've noticed the
majority of students in my advanced
classes are more inclined to agree with
the left on politics and other issues
I've also noticed that those in the
regular classes tend to agree with the
politics of the right I want to ask why
this is in my mind I feel there's a
distribution should be the opposite as
statistically speaking the members of
the right are generally more educated
and wealthy thank you for reading this I
hope your answer will help I think the
reason why it frankly is because one of
the ways that you do well in school is
by listening to teachers one of the ways
you do well in school is by mirroring
what teachers have to teach you not by
mirroring what your parents think and so
many of our schools are dominated by
teachers who are to the left that this
is this is a problem I think also that
people who tend to consider themselves
highly educated there's a high
correlation between between higher
levels of education phd's college
graduates and being of left then then
among people who are just partial
college graduates for example it doesn't
always line up with the earning power
but the studies that I've seen tend to
show that higher levels of education
tend to make you more of the left
because you tend to feel that you can
control Society that you if only you the
greatest and wisest of all beings were
to control society decide to be better
example when I went to Harvard Law
School which is of course the left's
favorite institution when I went there
the first day Elena Kagan who is now on
the Supreme Court was the deed and she
brought us it into a room there was a
mahogany beautiful room 500 students all
sitting there it's our orientation we're
all really excited to be there and she
says that she says listen you've heard a
lot about how Harvard Law is really
tuff you've heard a lot about how the
competition here is really brutal well
I'm here to tell you you've already won
the competition right you're in that
means you're getting a job you're not
gonna have to worry about anything and
more than that we have I think at the
time it was four out of nine Supreme
Court justices or three out of nine we
have 30 senators who go into Harvard Law
you one day the people in this room will
be the rulers of the universe you will
be ruling the world and so what you
learn here is what you're going to rule
with basically that's a pretty dangerous
message but that is also the message
that is being pushed to people who go to
institutions of higher education and
they believe it because when you're
smart you believe that you should be
able to control people who are less
smart and one of the things that's great
about the founders that they realize
that there will always be someone
smarter and those people will always try
to control you so we need to set up an
institution of checks and balances to
prevent that sort of control from ever
taking place Jake says - I think Moses
is considered above other prophets -
Jews but our prophets after him
Elijah Malathi Jeremiah considered as
Malachi sorry and considered as prophets
or just great teachers like Rambam like
Maimonides if they're prophets when did
you believe the cycle of prophets
leading the people stopped and why
thanks Jake so the answer is that in
Orthodox Jewish Canon the cycle of
prophecy essentially stopped with I
believe around the time of Ezra Ezra the
these the scribe the idea is that God
sort of withdrew his presidency was he
sort of hid his presence more in the
universe
Maimonides has a very interesting take
on this in in guide to the perplexed he
says that that essentially we lost
access to prophecy because we stopped
being able to access our reason in the
same way that we don't have as many
cultivated people now and if we were to
cultivate ourselves then maybe prophecy
would be opened up to us again but
nobody would ever be a prophet like
Moses but that's a controversial
perspective the era of prophecy ended in
according to traditional Jewish
perspective it ended because the Jews
essentially rebelled against God so many
times that God would through his
presence a little bit to let the Jews
have the brunt of it sort of that's in
very blunt that's a very basic way of
understanding it John said hi Ben I'm a
daily listener and a huge fan of the
show my question comes from last week's
mailbag when you said you were in favor
of mandatory vaccinations I agree they
should be mandatory due to positive
externalities but who would fit the bill
as it is now mandatory purchased would
it be the consumer alike mandated auto
insurance or would be covered by our
taxes or going to be something in the
middle where low-income persons are
covered
keep up the great work thanks well I
think that it would probably be if
people can't afford it then we help out
with with some sort of redistributionist
program because it is mandatory but if
you can afford it then you should be
paying for it because again it serves
your child as well as it serves other
children like you get in what you get
out I have a takings perspective of the
Richard Epstein book takings is really
good about this basically what he says
is the government can tax you to the
extent it provides you services in
return and this would be one of those
things right it mandates that you spend
money on a mandatory vaccine and it's
like car insurance you got to do it
because it has externalities Justins has
been do you believe the Democratic Party
is truly done with Hillary Clinton or
should we expect to see more of her in
the upcoming years I think she's toast I
think she just won't leave which is not
quite the same thing Michaels has been
of these three composers how did you
rank them Hans Zimmer Howard Shore John
Williams John Williams Zimmer Howard
Shore the only reason that Howard Shore
isn't ranked higher is because he's only
great score really is Lord of the Rings
here's a bunch of kind of okay scores
Hans Zimmer has a bunch of very good
scores I think he has a couple that
verge on the great John Williams of
course has a bunch of great scores
Michael says hey Ben I'm currently
finishing up my thesis for my undergrad
I chose to conduct my research on how
Publius thought federalism what should
work as he presented the state national
relationship in the Federalist I read
several critiques of the Federalist I
was wondering if you have a favorite and
why I also heard your wife is a doctor
is that true it is true Michael as well
as far as the Federalists the thing you
should read really is the anti
federalist papers which are a great
critique contemporaneously of the
Federalist Papers also there's a great
book on the history of political
philosophy edited by Leo Strauss and it
has an entire little essay on on the
Federalist so check it and so check that
out it's really interesting okay Ashley
says hi Ben can you recommend any
reading about the table platform swap
that took place between the Democrat and
Republican parties it's hard to find a
good source out there that isn't
completely biased I believe Dinesh
D'Souza's written about it I've written
about it as well and also stay tuned
because I will have a book coming out in
the near future through daily wire that
will be a refutation of all the leftist
myths that are out there like night 101
leftist myths debunked this is one of
them so we can check that out okay so
you should guess the things I like in
things I hate
okay let's do some things I like and
some things that I hate so the things I
like I've done a lot of Passover stuff
this week and so I've decided that it is
time to do an Easter thing so the
greatest Easter movie maybe
really great eastern movie of all time
because passion of the christ' really
isn't about Easter it's about Good
Friday but the the greatest Easter movie
of all time of course has been her that
doesn't mean it's the great it maybe I
should rephrase the greatest movie that
has the Easter in it is Ben Hur okay
maybe they're better Easter movies that
are like about King of Kings or
something and that actually tackled just
Jesus's story but this movie ends of
course with the Easter crucifixion of
Jesus and with it ends with the
crucifixion of Jesus and his blood
washes away the leprosy of been hers
family members the movie itself is just
a masterpiece the original don't watch
the romantic obviously the original with
Charlton Heston is an amazing film
William Wyler was the director and this
of course I'm about to show you is one
of the great scenes in movie history in
which Ben Hur is is in a chariot race
with misawa who is his kind of lifelong
former brother figure but now enemy and
Misawa is trying to trying to kill him
his he's got blades on on the spokes of
his wheels so here here's what this
looked like
[Music]
okay so I mean it's an amazingly shot
scene look how they see in a shot right
this is all like does not happen against
background right mean this is this is
done with it's just anime it's an
amazing film it's an amazing film and it
is of course the glass the great classic
epic it's it's it's so good and this
particular scene it cost a fortune to
shoot the there there was a rumor that
Alex was bringing up to me that someone
was killed during the making of the
scene oh it's not actually true so it's
worth debunking but the movie itself is
really worth watching so check that out
one of the great this is what Hollywood
does best right this is the epic stuff
that Hollywood does best just amazing
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so it is amazing whom the left will
continue to trot out so they've tried
out Hillary Clinton's talk about gun
control even though no one likes Hillary
Clinton and now they're trotting out dan
Rather to talk about how to avoid fake
news which is an amazing thing right dan
Rather was a Austin from his job in 2004
because he insisted that a letter that
was put out it was false it was
manufactured about george w bush's
service in the national guard showing
that he had actually gone AWOL is in the
middle of the election cycle was
actually true it was forcibly debunked
by the internet dan Rather stuck by it
he ended up losing his job over and now
he is on The Young Turks of course
talking about how to gauge fake news
it's pretty incredible stuff here is Dan
Rather number one understand that
trusting a news outlet does not mean
they're perfect no one's perfect
it means they tell you when they screw
up number two don't rely on just one
news outlet number three don't rely on
just the news to understand an issue
read books find the experts okay so
here's the thing I actually agree with
all the advice that the end rather gets
here right all we can stop there but I
agree with a lot of the advice game
rather gives the question is why you
can't find a better spokesperson for
this than dan Rather like I've said a
lot of the same things and again I think
what dan Rather saying here is is fine
but the left attaches to its people and
will not let those people go no matter
how bad they are is why you should go
see Chappaquiddick this weekend like
really if you want to see how bad it can
get before the left will still not let
you go go view Chappaquiddick and see
what teddy kennedy did and still
survives politically i mean the guy was
elected a thousand times in
Massachusetts and was considered the
wine of the Senate after leaving a woman
to die at the bottom of a river it's
still an amazing amazing thing okay
final thing that I hate so larry cudlow
is the new national economic council
chair for President Trump and in that
role he is he is essentially backing
Trump's plan a lot of this stuff I think
that what he's trying to do is convince
Trump that Trump's actual economic
policies can be turned toward a more
free-market way and that's that's the
sort of nice version of what Larry
Kudlow is doing but Larry Kudlow came
out and he backed trump's war on amazon
i just think this is not correct i think
the president's intent here is to
develop a level playing field between
online retailers and land-based
retailers with respect to taxes and
other issues I think that's his intent
create a level playing field has always
been confusion positive steps have been
made in some cases the Supreme Court's
going to make a ruling very soon on this
that will again move towards the level
playing field there was a time when we
wanted the United States as a matter of
policy wanted to protect you know
nascent internet businesses by keeping
down the tax burden but that time is
long gone so I just think the level
playing field is the best way to look
should the president be the one who is
out front on this tweeting like he has I
mean the president United States
president United States the president
United States do this is what we this is
this is really dumb okay so what Kudlow
is saying here when he's saying that
Trump just wants a level playing field
okay if you really want a level playing
field call for an end to state sales
taxes but Amazon is paying the state
sales taxes in all of these places right
if they are mandated to pay state sales
tax in 45 out of 51 jurisdictions in the
United States including Washington DC
they're paying the mandated sales tax in
those states
and what what Trump is really doing here
is he's mad because he thinks that
Amazon is killing brick-and-mortar
retail shops because they're
undercutting them you know why because
the Amazon is a better company sorry to
break it to folks but it's more
expensive for in brick-and-mortar than
it is to actually just send you stuff
through the mail
okay I've known this for years hey I'm
one of the hypocrites who goes to the
bookstore that I love views the books
online finds the one that I want I'll go
to the
so I look at it and then I will take out
my phone and I will see how much of
class on Amazon it's like a three dollar
difference I'll just buy it at the
bookstore but if it's a ten dollar
difference I'll buy it on Amazon right
I'm not gonna spend extra hundred
dollars just to go to a brick and mortar
shop I'm not sure why I should have to
and I don't see why it's the President
of the United States his responsibility
to make me as a consumer pay more just
because he has a fondness for brick and
mortar when consumers clearly don't I'm
not gonna subsidize brick and mortar as
a consumer why should i subsidize it as
a taxpayer okay well we will be back
here on Monday with much much more have
a wonderful weekend i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018